hey we've got the winner of this year's
Mojave Max emergence contest he's a
fifth grader from Rundle Elementary
School on the east side say hello to
edin Corden we went out and surprised
him at his classroom yesterday he
guessed the Taurus would crawl out of
his Burrough at the Springs Preserve 3
14 p.m April 24th actual time of
emergence 3 40 p.m really close so Ed
and his teacher there Mr Monk they're
getting free laptop computers at next
week's field trip to the Springs
Preserve where ednan is a whole class
will meet Max in person have a pizza
party we think the desert tortoise is a
better predictor of spring-like weather
than that groundhog Punxsutawney Phil
who lives in Pennsylvania proud to be
part of the Mojave Max team for more
than 20 years John